c'est déjà le 20e marie culturel et je
pourrai pas imaginer plus belle façon de
patiner samedi quand votre charmante
compagnie merci pour votre fidélité
c'est parti pour 30 minutes de culture
cette semaine
envie de re décorer votre maison avec
des oeuvres d'art originales sans vous
ruiner on vous parle des oeuvres d'art
al oui
[Musique]
c'est une figure incontournable du hip
hop d'ici un homme quelque 400 âmes un
repas cinq rapports
les marabouts raja gérald viennent nous
présenter le meilleur de la télé les
séries du moment à ne pas manquer
bienvenue à votre art et culturels
[Musique]
salue ici mais bien alexandre chartier
très heureux de vous accueillir pour ce
nouvel arrêt culturel où chaque semaine
on fait un panorama de tout ce qui a
marqué la semaine culturelle d'un bout à
l'autre du pays est un sujet dont on a
beaucoup parlé cette semaine louis
philippe c'est le superbowl la grande
messe du football américain qui avait
lieu dimanche dernier il y avait le
match bien sûr mais il y avait aussi le
spectacle de la mi temps que je crois -
ben mnm que mes genoux à terre on serait
pas c'est un hommage à tous pâques où
c'était un hommage un autre geste était
plausible interpellé car seulement et
c'était la toute première fois dans
l'histoire du super bowl qu'on avait une
programmation spectacle entièrement
consacrée au rap qui demande quand même
le style de musique le plus populaire
aux états unis écoutent chaque fois une
firme montréalaise pixma ben que le défi
d'éclairer tout ça en plein jour
absolument il avait la tâche d'éliminer
le public en donnant des petits
dispositifs équipés de lumières del qui
sont contrôlés à distance ça s'est bien
passé résultat exceptionnel pour cet
homme est connu des années un petit peu
difficile avec la pandémie est là les
choses vont de mieux en mieux il était
aidé à cette semaine aussi à dubaï pour
le lancement de la tournée mondiale de
compliquer les autres un nouveau
dispositif qui en plus recyclable
biodégradable donc un virage vert
deuxième bonne nouvelle mais philippe
dont on va parler cette semaine c'est
des investissements majeurs pour les
studios mel's à montréal je me souviens
abîmé l'an passé l'as far reportage la
production virtuelle au studio mer
l'idée c'est d'avoir un écrin de recréer
un déca beau temps mauvais temps on peut
donc tourné à l'intérieur et ça ça
permet de tourner des publicités entre
autres des téléséries mais aussi des
films à grand déploiement alors l'an
passé il y avait cet écrin magnifique
mais là cette année les grands et dix
fois plus grande il faut avoir des
investissements de plusieurs millions de
dollars j'ai pu visiter les lieux quand
même un plafond qui monte et qui descend
pour s'assurer d'avoir le bon effet je
me suis même amusé et j'ai couru dans le
tunnel ville-marie évidemment de façon
virtuelle sécuritaire et que c'est plus
sécuritaire l'idée c'est qu'il ya un bon
moment on en parlait au bon niveau des
productions montréal est une ville
chérie par les producteurs hollywoodiens
je me suis entretenu avec martin carey
qui est le président et chef de la
direction des studios mel's on écoute ce
qu'on veut faire chemise avec cette
nouvelle technologie l'os et oui attiré
des grands blockbusters américains comme
on a fait entre autres sur transformers
l'été dernier que utiliser une partie de
cette technologie là mais on veut la
rendre aussi accessible aux productions
québécoises
une bonne nouvelle pour l'industrie
cinématographique qui tourne à plein
régime parlant cinéma on doit souligner
le départ d'un grand nom de la comédie
le canadien ivan reitman fait que le nom
ne vous dit rien mais si on dit qu aux
masters un flic à la maternelle junior
sos fantômes le vous replacer ces
comédie classique des années 80 90 et
début 2000 et c'est l'homme qui était
derrière ces grandes comédies on
l'appelait le roi la comédie ivan
reitman et arnold schwazenegger qui
était très triste annonce de son décès
il a s'est exprimé sur les réseaux
sociaux en disant je t'aime monsieur
muscle mais il va rentrer mais n'a fait
de moi quelqu'un drôle de comics l'a su
trouver mon côté le plus givré que mehdi
qui ont marqué ma jeunesse merci
beaucoup de filet contre trouve un petit
plus tard pour ta rencontre avec
dramatique un rapport important est qu
un parcours fascinant à un rapport
absolument résilient très belle
rencontre merci vous pour en discuter
c'est tout à l'heure pour le moment nous
reparler d'une nouvelle pratique dans le
milieu de l'édition ça s'appelle
électeurs sensibles lorsque l'auteur
écrit hier propose une réalité qui n'est
pas la sienne mais des fois le recours à
ces gens issus des différentes
communautés culturelles pour relire le
texte et s'assurer que rien de choquant
ou de désobligeant une pratique déjà
courante aux états unis en europe et qui
se répand de plus en plus ici aussi ce
reportage
dans son roman la daisy d'errata marie
hélène poitras raconte quatre histoires
de métamorphose sous certains angles
elle est la femme qu'elle a toujours
voulu être entre autres celle d'un
personnage né dans un corps de garçon et
qu'il deviendra femmes j'avais
l'impression que je m'étais un peu nu
que j'avais un petit peu peur de patates
égratigné certaines sensibilités elle a
demandé à chris bergeron une hauteur
trans de relire son texte pour
identifier des passages qui pourrait
être offensant et pour donner des pistes
pour nourrir l'authenticité du personnel
mois dans le fond il y avait une
certaine forme d'autocensure que je
faisais avant de pouvoir avoir les
coudées franches et grâce à la lecture
sensible aux états unis certains en font
même une profession chez des éditeurs
comme scolastique ou la rédaction du new
york times qu'ils sont fréquents
c'est comme ça qu'on va qu'on va
construire des ponts et qu'on va réussir
à se comprendre en différant nation
c'est comme ça c'est en discutant séance
et du cac puis c'est en des colonisant
une manière de voir les choses à
l'association des éditeurs de livres on
en parle de plus en plus d'électeurs
sensible même si ce rôle n'est pas
nouveau on se rend compte que plusieurs
maisons d'édition travaille avec des
lecteurs sensibles depuis plusieurs
années mais il est nommé pas de cette
façon-là il envisage de mettre sur pied
une formation sur cette pratique une
bonne nouvelle pour l'éditrice catherine
leroux qui n'y voient pas une forme de
censure
lothar toute la liberté de prendre ce
qui l'intéresse et de rejeter ce qui lui
semble pas pertinente il rien des
directives dans ce processus là et au
contraire moi ce que j'ai pu observer
c'est que souvent c'est très très
fertile c'est ça donne des nouvelles
idées ça apporte de l'eau au moulin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on ne connait le rappeur dramatique avec
son groupe mozac yens c'est un homme au
parcours riche comprend le sens du mot
résilience après la pause pour par cinq
minutes dramatiques bougez pas
en février avec le temps un peu maussade
ont le besoin de beauté et de couleurs
c'est ce qu'on nous propose actuellement
au musée à québec c'est parti pour notre
tour du canada
ici tifa bourgeois nos musée national
des beaux-arts du québec ou manif d'art
lance aujourd'hui la biennale de québec
une vaste exposition sur le thème de
l'illusion et qui s'appelle les
illusions sont réels pour les soixante
dix prochains jours on pourra découvrir
le travail d'une centaine d'artistes des
sculptures de la peinture des oeuvres
d'art numérique audio vidéo des
installations également qui viennent
questionner cette frontière entre le
réel et l'illusion 34 lieux de la ville
de québec y participent l'exposition
centrales se situent au sein même du
musée national des beaux-arts du québec
d'autres institutions culturelles y
participent avec des oeuvres d'art des
installations intérieures et extérieures
également
ici mathy getty à winnipeg je me trouve
au pacte du voyageur devant le fort
gibraltar où se célèbre actuellement la
53e édition du festival du voyageur
cette année le plus grand événement
francophone de l'ouest canadien sera en
mode hybride pas très loin d'ici dans le
quartier saint boniface le centre
culturel franco manitobain propose une
cinquantaine de spectacles une série de
spectacles sera également diffusé en
ligne sur la chaîne youtube du festival
du voyageur ici au parc du voyageur les
festivaliers pourront assister à
différentes activités comme la tire sur
neige est également deux nouveautés avec
le feu d'infinité qui célèbre les
peuples métis et la boîte à chansons qui
propose des concerts mobile dans tout le
parc le festival du voyageur c'est
jusqu'au 27 février à winnipeg
et du côté de montréal jusqu'au 5 mars
prochain c'est le festival montréal en
lumière qui bossent son play
installations lumineuses projection au
spectacle de cirque avec les 7 doigts de
la main une nouvelle patinoire également
découvrir au centre-ville de montréal
une foule d'activités pour toute la
famille à découvrir jusqu'au 5 mars
prochain vous avez envie de re décorer
votre maison d'embellir votre intérieur
sans vous ruiner lui c'est possible de
vous tourner vers la location d'oeuvres
d'art et des organismes comme
l'artothèque à montréal ou encore comme
le musée national des beaux-arts à
québec qui propose des oeuvres d'art en
location est ce également possible du
côté de vancouver avec le hub en taule
show qui se déroule deux fois par année
et on peut louer des oeuvres d'artistes
locaux comme vous allez le voir dans le
reportage de l'hymne barnabé
depuis 1972 l'organisme note van oord
offre au grand public la possibilité de
louer des oeuvres originales créées par
des artistes de la région de vancouver
donc c'est à peu près le même principe
que la bibliothèque sauf que on a
l'option d'acheter six ans si on veut
donc on peut louer emprunter ou louer
des tableaux vous pouvez le faire direct
en 200 des murs à lamballe on en voit
avec vous et puis elle remplace une fois
l'exposition terminée les quelques 450
tableaux photographies et lithographies
sont entreposés à la galerie de notre
bonheur tu sois là cityscape community
of space où a lieu l'exposition le
public put s'y rendre à l'année pour
louer les oeuvres à un prix variant
entre 10 et 55 dollars par mois on a une
cliente qui loue depuis 2002 et elle
change tous les trois quatre mois il y
en a aussi à des entreprises c'est très
bien dans une salle de réunion ou dans
une salle d'attenté pour les cabinets
médicaux à nos clients si depuis
quelques années en fait c'est les
industries du film et de télévision
environ le tiers des oeuvres est en
location et 12% sont achetés note van
hunt sera mais 70% des revenus aux
artistes lepeytre longue que riz
participent à ce programme depuis plus
de 6 ans jeux vendus deux ou trois
oeuvres
et puis j'ai ce qui est bien c'est que
j'ai j'ai aussi des nouveaux
collectionneurs qui sont venus voir ici
au studio pour voir ce que j'avais
autres l'incurie a également loué des
oeuvres à la note ba1 avant de soumettre
les siennes
découvrir de nouveaux artistes
d'avoir accès à des oeuvres
ça permet aux gens décèdent route
ici l'une barnaby radio-canada north
vancouver
le rappeur dramatique un parcours
inspirant après une enfance difficile
dramatique s'est hissé au sommet du rap
québécois avec son groupe moyenne tout
récemment il vient de remettre cent
mille dollars à l'organisme 18 04 qui
aident à la persévérance scolaire
louvigny mais le rencontrer
[Musique]
jocelyn bruno alias dramatique je suis
très content de vous rencontrer parce
que vous êtes un pionnier du rap
québécois entre autres avec le groupe
mazzariol on va y revenir mais avant je
veux parler de votre projet royauté
c'est une compilation de douze chansons
écrites et réalisées par une trentaine
d'artistes issus des communautés noires
du québec que vous avez amassé 100 mille
dollars que vous allez remettre au fond
1800 0,4 pour la persévérance scolaire
et pourquoi avoir choisi de soutenir la
persévérance comme souvent et on voit
les colts on en a parlé rosso sous la
table dans le dos et à cette époque là à
l'âge de 15 ans au sommet d'un logement
je me rappelle d'un manque de ressources
puis ces jeunes enfants ont besoin d'une
passerelle vers le monde de l'emploi
aussi on en a on a un grave problème
d'homme d'employabilité
donc je pense que tous ces
encouragements et
bénéfique quoi votre carrière a commencé
d environ 25 ans dans le quartier
montréal-nord vous aussi à l'école henri
bourassa
vous avez déjà dit en tant que bègue
c'est l'europe qui m'a libéré parce que
j'étais timide et dépressif - comment le
rap vous à aider l'europe à aider à
mettre des mots ensemble sans que je
m'en charge dedans parce que ce sont le
rap comme vous remarqué que plusieurs
syllabes et que c'est de devoir sait pas
encore quand même temps puis le rappeler
je ne commette une grille le rap est
venu mais d'avoir plus de confiance en
moi le ramener
leur art change le cerveau c'est juste
la fable de falaise extractives des
parties du site en vie c'est pas rien ça
leur a pas changé votre vie au sommet ah
oui oui je pense que oui oui parce qu'à
cette époque-là en 89 j ai trois ans une
époque sombre chaque appartement à l'âge
de 7 ans à qui des amis pyrite champs
avec des mauvais coups tout seul sans
même l'avoir prévenue me mettre sur le
grill ce qui motive mon idole ne ne pas
arrêter leur a
fait une petite thérapie en soit j'ai pu
mettre tout mon tout le monde tout mais
des monstres sensei blanche n'a pas dit
pourquoi tu montes rhino dépendance au
système votre carrière a vraiment
décollé en 1996 avec maud zaïen deux
albums extraordinaires qui ont gagné
leur les phénix de l'année à l'adisq
que retenez vous de l'expérience mais je
retiens l'école en fait ces filles qui
me fera école et noah 7 points que l'on
vient d'une époque parce que diageo y
avait des gens qui meurent nous
rassemble est donc le chemin était pas
encore tracé encore on était un système
d'alarmé dans les styrènes un parti qui
va entendre parler des problèmes très
intelligent qui me met des problèmes en
dessous du tapis dont le français pour
sauver tout le long de votre carrière
vous avez manifesté contre la racisme
systémique et je pense particulièrement
de chansons l'oubli et révolte vert
comment voulez vous parler d'un sujet
aussi sensible
et comment ne pas en parler
on se fait piquer on souffre on se brûle
et je dis qu'il faut que ça soit quelque
part on garde les manifestations on
dirait qu'on est encore à l'époque que
des images en noir et blanc ce même
message ces phénomènes picken mêmes
manifestations c'est
[Musique]
c'est toute une onde finalement de
forces extra
travailler pour être acceptée en vrai
qu'on doit s'excuser de vivre puis
d'être là je sais que ça aujourd'hui
c'est un rôle important
je le sais ça on vous a vu dans
l'excellente série je voudrais qu'on
m'efface
l'écran en mode de vie trouve
l'expérience c'est génial moi même de
mon vivant jamais osé demander un rôle
parlant c'est rare qu'on voit des becs à
la télévision qu'on parle de
2,2 de diversité des 65 mio chif il ya
plein plein de gens qui sont des
campeurs des bleus prend la parole
la volonté de partager mon expérience
est plus forte que la voix de plus la
peur qui m'habite alors je fonce vous
voulez juste à m'inspirer des jeunes à
fond c'est parce que vous faites des
ateliers dans les écoles oui j'ai 100
qu'avez vous à dire aux jeunes
aux jeunes de jeu diront jeunes de
croire en soi de de dreux ne pas arrêter
des fois on en a des idées dans notre
tête qui nous rend heureux qu'il faut
continuer à nourrir cette flamme là et
c'est vous qui avez raison finale
j'espère qu'ils ont entendu ouais
dramatique merci beaucoup
j'essaye de dire moment son pdg mais
mais mais mais comme série en reggae mon
site il se fait de belles et de bonnes
choses en télé après la pause laima
bourrage à gérald vient de présenter ses
coûts car séries télé du moment qui
passe à tout
[Musique]
c'est mérité
what goes around or
c'est le moment à présent de par les
séries télé et pour ce faire on
accueille la charmante lannoy et
bourrage à gérard diamond rallye très
content de te retrouver tu débutes on
nous parle d'une série qui est écrit par
steve martin howlings
exactement c'est mon coup de coeur du
mois de janvier donc on suit trois
personnages trois inconnues un ancien
acteur un enfer réalisateur de broadway
est une jeune femme un peu mystérieuse
qui gardent l'appartement de sa tante
ils vivent tous dans le même immeuble et
un moment d'un écouter at il ya pour un
meurtre dans l'immeuble et ses trois
inconnus là qu'ils sont tous les trois
des fans de podcasts de troc rhymes et
d'essai de créer leurs propres monnaies
dans notre quête pour essayer plomb
qu'on méritait vraiment pas cela ils ont
trois inconnus mais ces trois super
vedette les paires traite ces trois
inconnus exactement donc on à selena
gomez qui joue avec yves martel et
martin short dont et et qui sont assez
lents dans la vie respective donc au
travers de cette espèce dans quête qui
mène dans l'immeuble c'est une belle
réflexion sur la solitude dans les
grandes villes j'ai trouvé cependant
trois personnes qui vivent elles peuvent
chacun en stylo et qui se retrouvent
autour de cette fameuse par sion le pour
l'enquêté rien qui est très très drôle
on rit beaucoup vraiment mon coeur du
mois de janvier
[Musique]
il faut regarder la télé pour le tabac
et c'est la deuxième suggestion c'est
quelque chose qui me parlent beaucoup
parce que moi qui jouait dans un bar
branché de gens qui aiment de république
dominicaine et c'est toujours une espèce
de spectacle et des gens qui jouent aux
jeux vidéo on obtient comme j'étais un
petit mouton qu'on est pas prêt
qu'attendre donc c'est toujours une
expérience traumatisante et enzo pour
moi donc je peux facilement imaginer que
beaucoup à dire sur les salons de
coiffure et si le sujet de la série
tenir ça tenait au ballon donc c'est
drôle que tu seras comme ça par quelle
animatrice et la concept 13,2 c'est de
cette série lost se fit for ont eu cette
idée là de l'afrique en qualité en
écosse et qu'elle se faisait elle même
coiffé par un coiffeur sénégalais est
amplement laisse et du mont-dieu
meilleur forcément un univers à explorer
et thriller c'est un excellent prétexte
pour aller à la rencontre de points de
communautés culturelles à travers la
province à travers le prisme des salons
de coiffure samedi presque milieu de vie
dans certains cas tout à fait parce que
les gens de la communauté se rassemblent
depuis la série ça devient vraiment un
espèce de micro classement fait pour
parler de plein de sujets en lien avec
la communauté qui nous intéresse donc
par exemple dans la saison 2 on suit un
coiffeur cubain mais au final on dépasse
le sujet du salon de coiffure parce
qu'on parle de son arrivée au québec de
tous les défis de peuvent représenter
l'immigration l'intégration
l'apprentissage de la langue et c'est
une série honnêtement qui fait tellement
du bien et je pense que ceux qui feront
l'effort
beaucoup parce que on sent tellement
sacré el khir used et sa bienveillance
son empathie pour les gens qui
rencontrent chaque fois
le professeur mal prononcé mon nom donc
bravo rhénatic pourquoi tu ton un nom
français on me dit tu appelles tu peux à
peine dix ans sa petite couronne j'ai
choisi comme ça alors c'est un
professeur qui a choisi ton prénom
fictif comme c'est comme un art si tant
est qu'il est très jeune et très
intéressant et à dernière suggestion
l'aema c'est un documentaire à découvrir
sur creil une fois ce tournoi exact
oui mais justement on parle du milieu de
l'humour en fait au québec à travers
différentes entrevues avec des
humoristes noir donc on va vraiment de
normand brathwaite à boucar diouf
anthony kavanagh michel mans barragiste
quand ils gagnent rien à jean lévy qui
est la première et la seule femme noire
diplômé de l'école nationale de l'humour
au québec moi je suis relancé du scion
poussée du le nomme chef fathi moi je le
regarde pas pu me marie
voir vraiment fait leurs différents
parcours et on les perçoit vraiment
comme des parcours de résilience des
parcours de beaucoup de persévérance
puis on voit vraiment stickers et
humoriste le souhaitent être des modèles
pour les jeunes aussi moi je pense que
c'est vraiment ce qui me touche le plus
c'est de voir que ils parlent de leur
parcours comme d'un chemin qu'ils ont
débroussaillé mais surtout de
l'importance de laisser les portes
ouvertes pour ceux et celles qui vont à
venir après le décret ce but respirant
ouais ben merci beaucoup pour ces trois
belles suggestions la ive a très hâte de
trucs pour d'autres suggestions qui pour
le moment nous avoir regardé des images
d'une fois c'est encore une fois ce
timbre sa provoc quoi en points et volé
suresnes blagues nulles qui va arriver
après ah c'est mon primaire au
secondaire ils m'ont fait tout les docks
de doigts est-ce que ça arrive des fois
qu'on a des bonnes surprises non
avec le plan de déconfinement qui se
confirme on assiste au retour des
grandes tournées internationales
notamment stromae qui sera au pays à la
rentrée prochaine refaire des spectacles
à vancouver toronto montréal et québec
on se quitte d'ailleurs cette semaine en
écoutant un petit extra merci d'avoir
été des nôtres ciao tout le monde à la
semaine prochaine fois j'aimerais
vraiment vers un ceux qui n'en ont pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pilote d'avion fourniret
deux camions hôtesse de l'air
boulanger ou marin pêcheur un verre au
champion des pires do rev jeunes
bercé par les aucun saugnac
et tous ceux qui sous peine de coeur
non pas que on
l'action
[Musique]
michael
réaction